[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
tiéman hubert coulibaly il a été
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
défense notamment du mali c'est le
président du parti union pour la
démocratie et le développement il est
avec nous en duplex depuis abidjan merci
d'être avec nous
bonjour merci pour votre invitation
monsieur coulibaly le mali a
officiellement dénoncé les accords de
défense le liant à la france est selon
le ministre malien des affaires
étrangères
cela veut dire qu'il n'ya plus de base
légale pour la france d'opérer sur le
sol malien quelle est votre réaction à
cette décision de la junte au mali cette
volonté avait déjà été exprimée depuis
depuis fort longtemps
cette volonté a été exprimée elle a été
exprimée par la rue elle a été exprimée
par les postures politiques et la france
elle-même a décidé du retrait de ses
forces il ya déjà un mois et c'est ce
retrait qui est en cours je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
une escalade déclarative il y à une
posture un peu plus un peu plus du qui
est prise
du côté malien mais je ne pense je ne
sache pas que cela change véritablement
la dynamique qui a engagé depuis
plusieurs mois les forces françaises
sont en train d'organiser leur départ
coordonnées du mali d'ailleurs avec les
forces maliennes et il ya un délai qui a
été prescrit pour cela il est évident
qu'après toutes ces années là de
présence opérationnelle
d'engagement
un tel départ est une opération délicate
qu'il faut faire de manière à préserver
même si la coopération militaire
opérationnelle même si la coopération
militaire stratégique devait s'arrêter
il y a quand même d'autres pans de la
coopération entre la france et le mali
qui doivent être préservés moi je pense
aujourd'hui que les vicissitudes de
l'histoire et des évolutions des
relations entre les états sont largement
en deçà des liens qui existent entre les
peuples et je pense que les peuples du
mali et de france ont des liens assez
anciens des imbrications des
implications et et un brassage qui a qui
a été tissée depuis bien des années je
vais maintenant au delà du siècle ce qui
fait que ces relations là doivent se
poursuivre au delà des vicissitudes que
nous vivons aujourd'hui en terme de
deux postures politiques ou de dynamique
on va dire circonstancielle mais est ce
que vous pensez pas que c'est un pas
vers une rupture diplomatique politique
entre paris et bamako est ce que vous
pensez qu'on en n'arrivera pas à cette
extrême
j'espère qu'on n'en arrivera pas là
j'espère mais il est évident que si l'
escalade continue si les actes de part
et d'autre de de défiance et de
confrontation ne serait ce que on va
dire
de position continue je crains qu'en
effet les relations diplomatiques et
politiques puissent prendre un coup et
cela serait extrêmement dommage parce
que le mali de mon point de vue
aujourd'hui doit continuer sa
coopération à raison de sa géographie et
de son histoire avec l'ensemble des
états qui l'entourent et ses états qui
l'entourent d'un point de vue le
militaire et de conduite de la guerre
contre le terrorisme ont décidé de
poursuivre leur relation avec ce
partenaire majeur qu'est la france et
dans le sillage de la france il y a
plusieurs pays européens est d'ailleurs
peut-être d'autres continents qui
suivent ce mouvement là parce que nous
estimons que la sécurité collective
requiert une action une mise en commun
des moyens un partage de doctrine eu un
partage du renseignement afin de venir à
bout
donc de ce phénomène terroriste qui
aujourd'hui est un phénomène mondial et
j'ajoute que aujourd'hui il ya des
dynamiques de polarisation à travers le
monde avec tout ce qui se développe
comme conflit est
comme future futuribles en termes
d'opposition de puissance
en tenant compte de cela moi je ne
souhaite pas que mon pays devienne un
terrain de jeu où un terrain
d'expression d'antagonisme aux mondiaux
ou sont au coeur des enjeux qui ne le
concerne pas mais est ce que ce n'est
pas déjà est ce que ce n'est pas déjà le
cas parlons clairement la russie à
travers le groupe wagner ou à travers
son influence n'est t'elle pas le
véritable maître aujourd'hui à bamako et
c'est ce que ce n'est pas elle qui
impulsent ses gestes ses déclarations
ses mouvements à la gente messieurs
sergueï lavrov il ya juste quelques
jours a annoncé que wagner était
présente en libye au mali et ailleurs
sur des bases commerciales et de ce
point de vue même si
plusieurs analystes disent que le groupe
wagner est un groupe lié au kremlin et
c'est moi je m'en tiens aux déclarations
des autorités russes le mali a des
relations avec la russie et cela est
bien parce que c'est un état parce que
le mali en tant qu'etat ne doivent avoir
des relations qu'avec des états la
coopération militaire racle la
coopération pour les questions de
sécurité doivent se tisser entre des
états j'ai toujours dit que j'étais
absolument contre la loi de mercenaires
dans mon pays parce que celui qui engage
un mercenaire se place automatiquement
entre les mains de ce mercenaire un
mercenaire qui vide la guerre jamais
nous fera en sorte qu'une guerre
s'arrête
parce qu'ils envient et je crois que les
états doivent avoir des relations avec
des états et non des mercenaires ou des
milices privées je crois que le mali
gagnerait à revenir dans l'est vers ses
fondamentaux dans une certaine
orthodoxie de la conduite de la guerre
contre le terrorisme
en exploitant les outils comme le g5
sahel en exploitant les potentialités de
la cedeao en matière d'organisation de
dépenses collectives et même au delà il
ya une architecture paix et sécurité de
l'union africaine qui peut être revisité
de manière à nous organiser et faire
face à nos défis aujourd'hui c'est le
peuple malien qui va payer le prix à
terme est d'ailleurs peut-être à moyen
terme pas très long de certains choix
qui sont faits aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement de transition alors je veux
en venir à la transition
la junte avait proposé une transition de
cinq ans puis maintenant elle propose 24
mois la cedeao a affirmé que ces seize
mois maximum vous faites partie d'un
cadre qui exige que les engagements de
la transition soit respectée est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que la junte au
pouvoir a décidé de se maintenir malgré
les sanctions malgré les diktats de la
cedeao
comment voulez vous qu'on puisse croire
à tout cela nous sommes déjà à 20 mois
il était prévu 18 nous sommes à 20
de cette transition n'a jamais tenu ses
engagements
je comprends très bien que quand
l'épreuve des faits à l'épreuve de deux
de l'exercice de du gouvernement ils
aient pu découvrir les difficultés je
comprends ça très bien à l'époque lors
d'un entretien que j'avais eue avec le
le patron de la junte je lui avais dit
qu'il faut ne fallait pas avoir d'
engagement de d'agenda caché qu'il
fallait mettre les choses sur la table
et que si nous devions procéder à une
prolongation de la transition que cela
se passe entre maliens pour éviter que
nous ayons des difficultés avec la
claque la communauté internationale mais
en fait ils avaient un agenda caché et
je pense que c'est parce que l'intention
première a toujours été de se maintenir
mais cela n'est pas possible et c'est
pour ça que je les ai appelés à renoncer
à cette aventure là à créer un cadre de
dialogue à l'intérieur pour que les
maliens puissent se parler mais au lieu
de ça c'est la menace qui s'exerce ce
sont c'est une chape de plomb c'est
certain c'est un régime de mon point de
vue dictatorial qui s'installeront sont
tous menacés et et vous avez bien vu les
leaders politiques aujourd'hui ont le
choix soit de se taire ou d'aller en
prison et l'autre voie c'est d'être
absent du pays et cela n'est pas bien je
pense qu'il faut se ressaisir revenir à
des pratiques plus républicaine pour
sauver le peu qui reste de notre
république et de notre démocratie
autrement vous avez vu ces sanctions qui
ont été imposées au mali nous sommes à
l'agonie dans ce pays ce sont les plus
pauvres qui souffrent ce sont les plus
pauvres qui souffrent et qui vont
continuer de souffrir à ce que les
effets de ces cinq sion là sur les
comptes publics les engagements qui
n'ont pas été tenues au niveau
communautaire les défauts de paiement
nous allons continuer pendant 10-15 ans
a travaillé pour résorber le les effets
de ce choc là il à l'environnement
international lui-même connaît une phase
économique extrêmement complexe
le renchérissement non seulement des
coûts du capital le renchérissement de
tous les cours de tous les facteurs on
va faire que nous nous retrouverons dans
une configuration économique extrêmement
difficile je n'oublie pas les défis du
climat aujourd'hui nous en sommes nous
en termes de production agricole
aujourd'hui nous en sommes tous en
termes de capacité à nous et notre
cheptel sur notre territoire mais autant
de problèmes donc nous ne parlons pas
nous en sommes nous en termes de
couverture santé pesant son goût en
termes d'efficacité de nos programmes
d'éducation et tout cela ce sont des
facteurs d'hypothèque sur notre jeunesse
sur le futur de ce pays la traîne
aliments et politique doivent
céder à la préservation de nos
conditions de résilience et de survie en
tant que nation très rapidement
on a parlé vous avez évoqué la chape de
plomb on a vu des leaders de
l'opposition omar mariko être inquiété
vous êtes vous même en exil abidjan ça
veut dire que vous et d'autres être en
danger à bamako face à un régime que
vous êtes qualifié de dictatorial
franchement mon cas personnel est très
peu de choses par rapport aux questions
que je viens d'évoquer oui je suis hors
du mali de fusion du mali parce que j'ai
estimé que c'était la voie la plus sage
d'autres aussi ont fait ce choix là
parce qu'il faut se préserver nous
sommes des acteurs politiques mais avant
tout nous sommes des chefs de famille
nous sommes des pères et des mères nous
sommes des grands pères pour certains et
nous sommes
pas parfois d'ailleurs chef de clan ou
de communauté donc nos vies sont
importantes pour certains
je suis triste d'évoquer la mémoire de
mon ami se veut boubèye maiga qui est
parti dans les conditions que vous savez
mais cela
n'aucun personnels ne sont pas ne sont
pas très important c'est l'avenir du
mali qui est important c'est l'avenir de
ce pays là que nous devons laisser à nos
enfants qui est important et ce de cet
avenir-là requiert que ces autorités
reviennent à des pratiques politiques
dignes de notre pain c'est mon hiver
coulibaly merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité aujourd'hui depuis abidjan
en côte d'ivoire et merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cet entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]